we're currently waiting on the Supreme
Court's decision really two decisions
about Donald Trump's tax returns and I'm
hoping to have news about that either
later on in today's program or if not
we'll talk about it tomorrow on the
Friday show with you but we do have a
new Supreme Court decision to talk about
that came out yesterday and if you've
been following the Supreme Court for the
last couple of weeks you might be aware
that we had some reasonable decisions
some correct decisions from my
perspective from the Supreme Court over
the last few weeks but we did not get
that yesterday the Supreme Court has
cited 7 to 2 with the Trump
administration to allow employers to
deny access to employees of free
contraceptive coverage if the reason for
wanting to deny free birth control is
religious in nature and this is mean
listen the the the 72 decision the 7
majority each had buried not all the
same reasons why they were with the
majority but the decision in and of
itself is a huge win for the religious
right and it is a loss for Obamacare as
well it's a loss for secularism and it's
certainly at least a win that the Trump
administration can claim now that this
is one of the few wins that the Trump
administration can claim is part of a
bigger discussion about what is the case
to be made that Trump has accomplished
anything and should be a wreck
re-elected or not not what I almost said
but that is really a case that Donald
Trump has to make that's not a case for
me to make but this is at least
something that went his way the daka
decision not going his way
LGBT discrimination decision not going
his way and the Trump administration has
actually tried a number of different
ways to hurt Obama care with different
regulations one such regulation is that
if you are a religious based employer
you now will be able to say our
employees people who have health
insurance under as a result of working
for us they will no longer be able to
get
free birth control one of the things
that Obamacare said was that birth
control is free to the patient they must
have full coverage of contraceptive
services and products as part of their
health insurance plans houses of worship
including churches temples and mosques
were exempt from that requirement from
the get-go some people were not aware of
that but a lot of nonprofit groups like
schools which could be religiously
affiliated or based hospitals which
could be religiously affiliated or based
were not exempt if you worked for them
they had to through their insurance
coverage that that you are offered as an
employee had to offer contraceptive
services at no cost
some of them objected right away and
they said that goes against our
religious beliefs how are we it is a
violation of our freedom of religion to
say we must allow we must provide no
cost at to the patient of course
contraceptive services when we don't
believe that those should be something
people avail themselves of on the basis
of our religious beliefs in came the
Trump administration and they said we
agree with the religious employers
requiring birth control coverage without
cost burdens the free exercise of
religion they put in place some
exemption rules where employers can say
we opt out their employees can still get
birth control but it wouldn't be free of
a cost through their health insurance
plan now since the Affordable Care Act
requires it what that meant in practice
is that the states where people live
would have to pay and states like
Pennsylvania and New Jersey said hold on
a second if employers are not required
to provide this through their health
insurance we have to pay for it and
that's not fair to us said Pennsylvania
and New Jersey
a lower court agreed with Pennsylvania
and New Jersey that is the decision that
has now been reversed by the Supreme
Court the 7tu to vote in the Supreme
Court had Ruth Bader Ginsburg and Sonia
Sotomayor as the only dissenters
the majority said these restrictions put
in place by the Trump administration are
okay and for me the major takeaway and
what I want to remind you of is that
this is another explanation another way
to remind ourselves that health
insurance should not be tied to
employers period that that's my takeaway
and of course you can fight the legal
battle and that's exactly what the Trump
administration did but at a higher level
health insurance tied to employers is
the wrong direction and the in terms of
how far this goes there is a slippery
slope question here as well I mean if
you look at I don't know Christian
Science Christian Science is very much
against all sorts of medical care would
antibiotics be a legit exemption if they
are religiously based if Christian signs
says listen we run this big Christian
science you know reading room or
whatever they call it and we don't want
to provide antibiotics with we don't
want antibiotics to be so accessible
would that be valid I mean how far does
this go now the estimates are that
somewhere between 70,000 and 126
thousand women are going to lose
contraceptive coverage as a result of
this decision and what this really is is
pointing back to is this is an
administration the Trump administration
that has lost on policy Trump was going
to repeal and replace Obamacare failed
he was gonna build the wall failed he
was gonna fix this fix that fix the
other he's failed on essentially
everything they are now fighting a
culture war remember that Donald Trump
is not religious this is merely
pandering and it is a win on paper for
Donald Trump how much of a big deal he
makes out of this win remains to be seen
but this is a cultural war if you look
at the last six weeks you know the right
loves to accuse the left of fighting a
cultural war the reality is that it's
trump who faced with losing on just
about every policy issue is now talking
about we've got to fight these radical
Marxists mark there's barely any
Marxists and certainly none in positions
of power in the United States this is
about our heritage visa vie monuments
and the Confederate
flag and it's about free speech these
are culture war type battles and again
this you're not really damaging
Obamacare in the sense of removing it
the way he wants to do
you're just making life more difficult
for seventy thousand to a hundred and
twenty six thousand more women and Trump
who is not religious continues to pander
to the religious right through these
types of arguments and regulations so
that's what it all is really about
there's stunning hypocrisy as well
because you block access to birth
control but then do you do you provide
parental leave paid parental leave when
the baby is born
many many employers do not in their
certainly not mandated to etc etc I
think you get the idea but at least on
paper it is a win for the Trump
administration a win that they
desperately need because these wins are
so few and far between
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time favorite apps called blink it's
blink Isleta consume an entire book on
your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
non-fiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blink Asst blink east
has books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video